[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the most wonderful time of the year
the Super Bowl are you implying that the
Lombardi Trophy is here at the Cromwell
it is and since we don't get to go to
the Super Bowl the good news is we're in
Vegas weekend so bad on it I like where
your head's at
that's easy money how much cash did you
bring dad I didn't bring cash but I do
have cash out perfect
[Music]
Wow Chad have you ever been this close
to the Lombardi Trophy I absolutely have
not despite playing so many years right
now I am losing my Lombardi virginity we
love to touch it to touch another man's
shoes it's all about etiquette ah Chad
it's fine they make a new one every
single year okay in reverse order name
the teams that have hoisted this trophy
thousand bucks for whoever loses but
most are patriots obviously last Eagles
Patriots Broncos the Patriots Seahawks
Saint Raven I thought you had it
listen we're self-taught mix of winters
with that being said I need to run to
the ATM all right Chad have a great time
in Miami we got a show to shoot I love
you guys we love you too is there an
author's they go prop bet for a cameo in
the Jennifer Lopez Shakira have that job
yeah it's gonna be like plus
[Music]
184,000
[Music]
[Music]
shout out to the Cromwell for hosting us
and the Lombardi Trophy tele woodchuck
sends me that rack I'm gonna be
sprinkling like salty on about 10 prop
bets that's true but we got to catch up
listen for about five seasons Seattle's
defense pulverized the NFL while
carrying one of the baddest nicknames in
sports history the Legion of boom now in
this decade
Kansas City's Legion of zoom on the
other side of the offensive ball is
aiming to start its own legacy and that
legacy begins by terrorizing one of the
founding members of the Legion of boom
Richard Sherman this is our super boy
MVP no yes he is yours and probably mine
too
action no machi we're in this together
this is the B are betting show the Super
Bowl edition presented by the Caesars
Palace sports club
I'm cabby Richards and she is our
betting expert Kelly cow Shanahan
Stewart oh my goodness I knew that was
coming you screwed me all up that Niners
defense doesn't have a catchy nickname
but is one of the fiercest in the NFL
they have nine sacks three interceptions
in their last two playoff games they say
that defense wins championships in San
Francisco has one of the most dominant
defenses but at the same time they're
the underdog here in Vegas crazy right
it's absolutely crazy here's the crazy
thing to cabbie
it's estimated that 6.8 billion dollars
will be weighted on this year's
Superbowl
are you the six or the point eight of
the billion cabbie lady never tells with
some of the larger wagers in town have
been made public and I got to spend some
time with Jim mcinvale
aka mattress Mac a few days ago when we
completed our be our bedding truck Draft
you can see the results on our social
channel if you're betting but after we
finished we got to cruise over to Mirage
where mattress Mac place a
million-dollar wager on the Niners money
line there are like hundreds of people
lined up in line waiting to make wagers
will probably wager about you know 10%
of what Matt just Matt put down this is
my first Super Bowl in Las Vegas and
it's going to be sick I'm so it's gonna
be so sick cabbie this is going to be
such a good game let's go to the tale of
the tape
this is how these two teams have stacked
up for a betting perspective this year
and as you can see straight up against
the spread these two teams are very
competitive they have similar records
here and even when it comes to the
totals I know everybody told me how
crazy I was betting those Kansas City
unders this year but look it's almost
dead even on both now these two teams
took a different path to get to where
they are to the Superbowl today let's
see how their futures odds have changed
san fran 52 why there were 18 teams with
a better rec are better odds to win the
Super Bowl Kansas City was the odds-on
favorite at six to one San Fran crushed
everything that Vegas set for them this
year so congratulations to them then
after week 7 San Francisco was
undefeated down to 8 to 1 to win the
Super Bowl now remember mahomes got hurt
in that Broncos game so Kansas City's
odds went up a little bit with that
unknown factor the following week San
Francisco blows out Carolina now 7 to 1
Kansas City sitting at 12 to 1 they lose
the Green Bay they lost three of their
four games they reached their highest
odds of the season now headed into week
14 Patrick mahomes is cruising he's
healthy San Francisco beats the New
Orleans Saints and that crazy
high-flying game to 4 to 1 and here
after week 17 we sit today plus 350 IQ
the San Francisco 49ers do you believe
that gotcha new homes dislocated
it was in the Super Bowl it was so bad
cabbie if someone who's went through
that injury I was like no way this man's
coming back you cannot recover and he's
just a beast he came back and I'm very
happy for Patrick mahomes all right so
this is where we sit right now
all right cabbie this is exciting so
here's what we're looking at for the
Super Bowl today now we've talked about
on the show before the spread and the
money like don't always correlate with
one another and that shows right here if
you like the Chiefs just bet the money
line you do have to lay 110 plus or 105
so it's an interesting aspect on if you
want to bet the Niners how you should
bet it I do think you go with the money
line this is gonna be one of those games
where there's about an 8% chance that it
lands 1 or 2 so you may I see this
friend coming to play but historically
this has not been a thing I'm really
looking forward to seeing the gate
watching the gamesmanship between Andy
Reid and Kyle Shanahan leading into the
leading into the strengths of their team
for Kyle Shanahan it's the surging
rushing offense and on the left coke
podcast Warren sharp points to 1 under
the radar prop that worth look worth
betting on Kyle use checks first catch
over 5 and a half yards why everybody
think that there's a lot of plays in the
Superbowl and he's gonna have a bunch of
targets and maybe he could get like 11
and a half receiving yards which is his
receiving total for this game but I
think he might have with all the
different plays that are being called
one or two catches in this game so
you're banking like that that he's gonna
go over that with one or two catches if
you're taking his yardage total however
his first reception the way I see it
playing out is you know how Shanahan has
dialed up a couple of great plays for
how use checking Jimmy G tends to throw
the football to the open guy so if
there's a linebacker or that play is
covered he's probably not throwing it to
him for a 3 yard game right right he's
gonna throw it to him if he's running
open down the field
he's check seed you're gonna catch it or
he's not but that's why I like that crop
as opposed to betting his yardage total
Thank You Warren sharp and Adam left go
hit smarter reading Warren's Twitter
feed which you can find at sharp
football Kelley I've seen your notes and
your spreadsheets in your weekly
preparation so you can appreciate the
level of detail that Warren dives into
we're making his football analysis what
did you make of his college juice check
analysis the only thing I don't like
about as I couldn't find a spot to
better this morning after I saw that was
his favorite prophet of the week I think
he's absolutely right
Kyle Shanahan is gonna have to game a
little bit differently against the
Chiefs if he wants to win I like the use
deck over five and a half yards on his
first reception he's hit this one
perfectly spot-on and good luck I hope
you guys can find it cuz I sure could
I'm rocking with you cuz prop that to
make every Super Bowl party more fun and
here are a few more that we're looking
at starting as we mentioned earlier
patch of homes that can't believe this
guy at a dissonant dislocated happen
here he is and last week running four
touchdowns against the the Tennessee
Titans but here we are in the super ball
rushing yards over/under 33 and a half
what are you leaning on this one job so
truth be told I text our buddy bill
Kraken Berger about this one because I
knew that this was gonna be overvalued
but as you mentioned Patrick mahomes can
go up at any time for 20 yards here 10
yards there and this part that gets
blown up in your face but this is one of
the most heavily prop bets of Super Bowl
Sunday so this is bookmakers have done a
really good job on this number I know
that Niners fast grocers gonna get to
mahomes which is gonna cause him to
scramble just a little bit but I also
think it's gonna cause him to throw just
a little bit more I actually like the
under here I have this line set at 28
and a half sometimes we're getting five
points about our 5 yards of value now
again I know it's a little touch and go
whenever you're betting unders with
Patrick mahomes but I do like the under
here
speaking of throwing let's go to our
next prop that Tyreke he'll total
receptions over 5-1 30 under 5 + 110
which way you're leaning on this one I
think the bookmakers here in see there's
Boston 8 great job on this one this one
has quickly become one of my favorites
and I actually found a 5 and a half
that's on this one so chop around guys
see if you can get that extra half a
catch a value because I do think this
one's gonna land 5 there's a reason why
these guys have 1 to 5 and a half and
they just started juicing the over the
Niners will need to take out the Chiefs
the best wide receiver no that's not
Travis Kelce he's the tight ends I had
to tell our graphics guy that earlier
he's pretty fun that being said I like
the under plus money here Travis custom
does playing like a wide receiver though
this is maybe the most fun of the
process of scoring prop shortest
touchdown yardage open for one and a
half plus 135 under one and a half - 155
this is basically will there be a goal
line touchdown score absolutely and it
happens every single game it seems we're
gonna touch on this red zone defense
here a little bit at the end of the show
but I do believe this one's going under
its juice a little heavier than I prefer
again shop around guys see if you can
find a little bit under but will there
be a goal line touchdown absolutely and
finally the pollute report Super Bowl
prop our very own rookie Devo Samuel
rushing yards over under 14 I told you
guys on Wednesday when this one is 15 in
the half you've got a bet the under went
down to 14 out 14 today here on Super
Bowl Sunday again our boy Chad Johnson
talked about debo Samuel in the slot the
guy is a beast there's no reason to use
him in the backfield
stop thinking of that recency bias I
know but he's done the last few games
but again Kyle Shannon's gonna have to
change things up if he wants to beat the
Chiefs twas the night before the Super
Bowl and all through the casino the
social team was stirring making prop
bets so that we know where to spend our
money making wages with care in hopes
that Benjamin Franklin's would soon be
there are social too
[Applause]
Thank You Trey daddy plus 15,000 please
don't be the veggie straight guy make
sure you bring scoops not the triangle
break in half
pyaare sleepover at Caesar's Palace in
this palace sports book
[Music]
just like who's gonna be mad that you
brought beer core exactly 149 million
dollars I like the knife percuss bread
at VRS
what's up man it stuck to my boys at
Caesars and they hooked it up with the
official BR Betty trumped our social
team has the most fun and we're giving
away free swag bags
if the BR prop goes over so nobody's
getting swag who set this up I
definitely think it we should give it if
it goes under but we also became to the
duty so we'll give away something like
all you have to do is post [ __ ] scuse me
follow us on social ad vr underscore
betting and tag a friend I definitely
need to make a wager on a Russian prop
because we need to make running backs
great again san francisco's where he
most art can definitely wear one of
those red caps if they ever existed side
note there's no word on whether or not
Kyle Shanahan lost this backpack at this
year's Super Bowl like you did three
years ago the Atlanta Falcons so maybe
just maybe most hurt or Ted Lee Campbell
will have a couple of trick plays to
execute tell me which side are you're
leaning on for Super Bowl 54
oh this is so tough cabbie and I've been
saying this for basically two weeks now
I don't have a big opinion here now this
one open at a pickup open 51 and a half
we've seen both of these bounce around
throughout the week I just can't pull
the trigger now Ceaser saw some sharp
action on the under once it reached 54
and a half he reached 55 some other
spots here in town and I didn't get
there fast enough
I do lean towards the under here but
something to consider this is just the
third Super Bowl with the line of two
points or less that's right run 54 Super
Bowl 54 and only three of them have
fallen within this margin of victory the
only Super Bowl to fall with actually
within the margin of victory under three
points was Superbowl 25 Bills vs Giants
I'm actually praying for this game to
land on one or two and victory of the
Chiefs little side action I have myself
but there's only an eight point eight
percent chance of that actually
happening just know if I'm cheering for
that on social media that's why I do
lean towards the Chiefs in the under
again I'm sorry guys I did not get to
the window on the side or a total but I
do have a best bet for you guys on the
[Music]
now stop bets are all about how you
anticipate a game going and why didn't
get to the window on the under because I
missed the best of the number
I do feel expecting both defenses to
show up especially in the red zone and
that is why I like the over three and a
half field goals made love Eagle
Harrison but Kirk lets go cheering hard
four field goals and not touchdowns now
let's recap all of my Super Bowl picks
these are listed in order of confidence
on how many units I'd recommend you bet
on each so I've got a three unit play on
total field goals made over three and a
half Tyreke Hill under five receptions
two units on Patrick mahomes under
thirty three and a half rushing yards
one unit on the shortest touchdown under
one and a half yards and again guys
because I know you want to know what I
like which I don't I'm not personally
investing the side of the total I lean
towards the chips and beyond are you
actually junkies I don't like get your
stadiums for losers except for today
taking us for winners and an elite
defense with a suffocating front floor
versus a generational talent at
quarterback with the track team of
receivers I'm so excited for Niners vs.
Chiefs this is the BR Betty show the
special Super Bowl edition it has been
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book keep up with our social team at br
underscore betting to track all of our
Super Bowl activities and don't forget
to join us live at half time for our
final show of the football season
without first-half analysis updates and
all my picks and maybe a second half
player too good luck on all your bets
and happy Super Bowl Sunday
[Music]